bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france al qaïda au sahel
groupe de soutien l'islam et aux
musulmans a revendiqué via son agence de
propagande l'attaquent déjà coûté la vie
à trois soldats c'était lundi dernier
est ce que vous pensez réellement
d'abord que ce groupe est derrière cette
première attaque est la seconde peut
être également mon poids
la revendication est la proie de pialat
la fille nature je crois qu'il n'y a
aucune raison de douter du fait que ce
groupe r
hélas cette attaque et je serai aussi
très probablement s'ils sont des rousses
il à la nouvelle attaque
je crois que grax groupe honda et
s'attendent pas à observer comme on dit
le ciné accalmie il avait une carriè
dans beaucoup de data et maintenant les
peines est ce que les attaques de façon
beaucoup plus sophistiqué et dont il
avait dû se poser la question crée le
lien entre les niveaux de sophistication
de ces attaques et qui verse elhorga
libération des deux otages alors
justement puisque vous parlez du
financement de ces groupes
ces groupes il ils peuvent sar mais
alors comment est ce qu'ils arrivent
justement à s'armer et d'autre part qui
sont ces groupes djihadistes qui sont
actifs au celles contre lesquelles
l'opération barkan avec l'appui ronces
et d'autres forces comme le g5 mène une
guerre je ne sens pas une fois les
groupes sont composés de ce qu'on
appelle les katibas la katiba sur son
quartier quand on prend un peu la
technologie militaire sert que comme les
patrons
vous avez là dans la partie nord du mali
effectivement de cigales ménaka et macao
et dans une moindre mesure aussi
tombouctou voudrais surtout la présence
les jardins saint jean des fardiers
autour des cadavres ali et qui songe
aussi à harry
avec nos anciens du musée ou d'encre
sont découpées listel avant l'opération
servat n'a peut être pas sincère dans
ses goûts se sont un peu et papiers il
sera en fait reçu des accords autour de
ryad et harry parce qu'on appelle le
centre du marié certaines régions de
mopti ségou est maintenant un peu
koulikoro c'est essentiellement de la
katiba du macina et qui est en fait au
niveau 2 le burkina a souri à l'islam
mais tous ces enfants allégeance à le
groupement de soutien à l'islam et aux
musulmans
alors il ya eu un accord signé en 2015
c'est l'accord d'alger entre bamako
d'une part et la coordination de
l'azawad le mouvement de la rébellion
touareg
est-ce que ça quel rôle cet accord peut
jouer aujourd'hui dans les événements
qui se déroulent au sel la cua a été
fier avec des mouvements qui se sont
démarqués des mouvements écologistes
rqge finale à la chaîne à la
coordination des mouvements
le laser yag et la plateforme qui est ma
femme aussi développer le mouvement qui
sont plutôt des bovins qui sont
favorables à l'état malien les
mouvements qui se sont démarqués et
historiquement de toutes les actions
terroristes et les gouttes et logistique
et là c'est que sakho la partie la plus
importante
ce soit les agréments sécuritaire est la
possibilité pour certains combattants de
ce mouvement intégré les forces de
défense et de sécurité du mali et je
crois que si c'est ainsi que ce qui
avait été fait la risée attend il y
aurait eu au moins ces gens qui
connaissent le terrain et qui peut faire
face un peu augmenté nos listes et elle
l'héritage qui a été pris à
l'application de ces arguments
sécuritaires
aujourd'hui c'est que le trio
la metal qui entraîne de justes sur
l'armement des groupes terroristes
qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous dire vous
savez c'est l'argument émettre des
hypothèses
parce que je n'étais pas déjà que ce
soit en sport c'est pas des accents
actes sud et c'est que je crois qu'il
faut les attaquer les récupère beaucoup
de beaucoup d'âme et je sais aussi
qu'ils ont aussi des moins que la peine
était d'acheter des âmes
vous avez actuellement un marché d'armes
à ciel ouvert que la ligne et la libye
après kadhafi est pratiquement il y
avait également dalle qui sont déposées
il en parle même de certains personnes
auraient dû les coordonnées gps et qu'il
voit le plus offrant je crois que c'est
en fin à la pauvreté est plus aussi des
âmes que son équipe est alors cette
question puisque il ya plus d'une
cinquantaine de soldats français qui ont
péri au sahel depuis 2000 13,5 cette
semaine c'est un déploiement de 5100
militaires sur place est au coeur de
l'opération barkan est ce que on se
dirige selon vous va un désengagement
une réorganisation des forces françaises
dans la région
je ne sais pas parce que je ne veux même
pas a eu tellement de là dans la région
parce que pour moi elle tel déploiement
d'un homme intelligent qui est
actuellement difficile et ne comprend
pas de sens la présence surtout pour la
formation de m des armées nationales
essentiellement admettant aussi aller à
l'intérêt du dispositif les haras
national de rassurer la formation
l'équipement mais le fait d'avoir greffé
d'une fosse à l'iran des finales
nationales que cette fois déjà reçue par
la femme les opinions nationales comme
une force d'occupation
la france en tant que traductrice de
fond à fond sans train de perdre de
l'argent
l'avant-centre est aussi de les perdre
ses fiches mais à l'été elle était su
comme une fois le pied patients parce
qu' elle ne s'est pas intégrés dans les
armées nationales elle et elle touche
toutes les interventions que les faits l
effet en dehors de ce côté je crois qu
il faut revoir un peu au delà ils ne
veulent pas la guerre on ne gagne pas
seulement par les dames on gagne aussi
la guerre
pratiquement pas la communication
surtout pas les faits d'avoir l'adhésion
populaire la fin de set à déjà populaire
c'est parce qu'on vous parlait justement
du fait qu'elle ne soit pas assez
intégrés au sein des armées nationales
vous faites allusion peut-être roger 5
celle qui est composé des différents
membres justement de la sous région et
qui agit parallèlement à l'opération
barkan pour faire la leçon et j'espère
que ça elle rapporte à beaucoup de
questionnements calmer et mille fois
avec les commandes à avaler je n'avais
pas pensé qu'il fallait les faits
l'armée nationale collaborer entre elles
c'est vrai que ça d alba qui sent le
baril soit plutôt bilatéraux et chaque
année sous le commandement pour ce
commandement pas parce que la mer est il
que cela met sa touche à la souveraineté
des états c'est un cri armée
supranationale déjà fait malgré cela
j'ai pas que dans les familles plutôt a
forcé les différentes salles des
nationales et à renforcer aussi la
coopération internationale la
coopération bilatérale qui existait déjà
fait quoi on a voulu greffer que le feu
ne dirais pas semble-t-il c'est le cas
déjà dedans renforcement de la
coopération sécuritaire au niveau
bilatéral a on le voit avec l'union
européenne avec la france notamment nord
se passer parce que je ne parle pas de
château coopération bilatérale n'est pas
de la coopération par exemple le burkina
et le mali qui vont boucler leurs
forfaits respectifs chaque étage ce soit
la même chose entre les vallées
les bousculades et ainsi de suite
peut-être que les huitièmes que le panda
le nom européenne rebondissait de la
formation ils font de l'information
surtout à acapulco quête clicquot est
déjà très loin du théâtre des opérations
réalisées ils ne s'adonnent pas quelle
formation
il ya beaucoup d'intervenants il ya
beaucoup de courage et merci à vous pour
cette analyse yagg
mohamed ali merci pour avoir répondu
justement à nos questions directes vous
êtes chercheur à l'institut de veille et
d'études des relations internationales
et stratégiques liveris